Imagine a future where every Dynamics project moves faster,
makes better informed decisions,
and continues delivering value long after go-live.
This is the vision for Project MIA,
an agentic platform connecting people, decisions,
and delivery knowledge across the journey.
MIA begins in pre-sales,
helping teams create customer-relevant demos and data,
respond to RFPs,
and turn recorded demos and discovery workshops
into reusable project knowledge.
When the statement of work is signed,
MIA uses those artifacts to draft the project charter,
establish the delivery team and work streams,
and embed success by design into project execution.
MIA creates a first pass of requirements from discovery
and strengthens them as workshops continue.
It maps requirements to process flows
and performs fit-gap analysis.
For fits, MIA drafts configuration plans for expert approval.
For gaps, it evaluates customization,
power platform, and ISV options,
preserving decisions and an audit trail.
MIA unites teammates around one solution blueprint,
surfacing critical decisions while coordinating migration,
testing, and defect resolution.
As go-live approaches,
MIA coordinates cut-over and user readiness
while creating tailored training guides and videos.
And after the implementation team rolls off,
MIA is still there,
monitoring environment health,
explaining upcoming features,
analyzing their potential impact,
and helping customers continue to get more from their dynamic solution.
That is the vision.
Today, MIA is focused on helping implementation teams
turn project knowledge into coordinated, traceable delivery.
MIA begins by consuming project documentation.
It drafts requirements,
links them back to source evidence,
highlights missing information,
and suggests targeted questions for the business.
Once a requirement is adopted,
and it is understood,
MIA translates it into a configuration plan.
A Workstream lead reviews and approves the plan.
MIA applies the configuration
and records what changed,
why, and who approved it.
For data migration,
MIA helps interpret source data,
map it to dynamics,
define transformations,
and guide validation and loading,
keeping the migration connected to the requirements
and processes it supports.
This is MIA Today,
making implementations more rapid,
reliable,
and repeatable.